he said did you know  it takes less muscles to smile  than brown  and now i am aware that my neutral face  is not particularly chipper  like i do look like someone stabbed the  potato with a spoon upside down honestly  like  no muscles  neutral now i have resting face that's  what it's called only women have resting  [ __ ] face men simply have very  important thoughts you best not  interrupt them having i mean i'm waiting  for the joke here i'm way the the potato  what is that  potato with a fork in it upside down  i don't know what that was for all you  women out there just so you know a  little bit of mansplaining okay  you are not being specially targeted  when people tell you to smile you really  aren't was i just mansplaining just now  men do get the same thing people say to  me all the time  i don't like it it's annoying but then  again i don't like it when anyone says  anything to me about anything ever